good afternoon and welcome to the very
short ncbi minute odd alerts for new
data as per usual this recording as well
as the slides will be available both in
the youtube channel the webinars
playlist and on our FTP site you can
find links for those things here it'll
give you just a minute to copy those
links down alright so over the next few
minutes we're going to talk about
setting up alerts for new data using my
NCBI I'm bed buzzy I'm the
bioinformatics training lead here at
NCBI and I have with me Peter Cooper who
is ahead of the NCBI education group so
many of you most likely use NCBI
literature resources and many folks are
very used to using my NCBI to do regular
literature searches however many of our
users do not know that you can also save
searches for data for example for new
assemblies or annotations for new geo
data sets or even for new sra data sets
and just going to walk you through how
to do that over the next few minutes so
the majority of you probably know that
my NCBI is simply a way to have an
account at NCBI and it's trivial to sign
up for a my NCBI account in fact when I
was preparing this webinar I signed up
for a my NCBI account simply such so
that I could have a fairly clean
demonstration slide so it's a reasonably
easy thing to do there are many folks
out there with my NCBI account and i
highly encourage you to get one so
creating alerts from any search string
of my ncbi ncbi is quite simple really
all one needs to do is click the create
alert button below
the search that they're already doing so
say I was searching geo for all divers
at human might only want data series as
I showed here then I can click the
create alert button and the alert dialog
box would come on I could modify my
search term I could need my save search
I typically use the defaults but if you
were to do a lot of these I can see how
you'd want to name them in a more
systematic way you can keep your filters
or not and there are a bunch of ways you
can get email updates so this is really
quite simple to use and a lot of people
have told us that they would like to see
this service which in fact exists as i
mentioned earlier you can also get
alerts for bacterial annotation and
assemblies this is particularly useful
in my opinion in the microbial realm for
example if I wanted to see new releases
of Salmonella either assemblies or
annotations I could do this search in
the NCBI assembly database I believe
personally that the NCBI assembly
database is a very very clean and useful
resource for finding genome assemblies
also if you were to do sra searches for
example for metagenomes you can do that
the search I've done here is for
digestive decontamination a fascinating
thing that is sometimes done to folks
patients in intensive care units and
here you can see a time course of such
such experiment interestingly enough you
can blast into this time course to look
at different bacterial gene loci that
return to the human gut after this
massive course of antibiotics but this
search I could also save once again
simply by clicking on the create alert
icon another nice thing that my NCBI
will do for you that men
folks don't know about is it'll save
custom tracks both track configurations
that you can set up in the NCBI genome
data viewer by clicking on the tracks
button but also data that you upload so
here I've uploaded a file called test
bed and my NCBI will save that so as
with all of our resources we have
documentation you can get those from the
NCBI learn page and if you just Google
for NCBI webinars it's an easy way to
find the NCBI webinars page my favorite
way to get to this documentation page is
to go to ncbi / learn and then you'll be
able to go to the documentation once
again an updated version of these slides
will appear on the ftp site in
approximately one hour from now and some
of these links will be a little bit more
simple another thing i do in my position
at ncbi is I run a hackathon we have a
bunch of Agathon's coming up so if you
can do some you're pretty familiar with
linux and you can do some basic
scripting you're interested in
bioinformatics or medical informatics
you should consider coming to one and
these are the hackathons we have coming
up right now and they're look to be some
interesting what's also shaping up for
spring of 2018 in my group i also have
intensive internships for grad students
postdocs and clinicians so you can come
work here for four to six weeks on
either your project or ours in a
collaborative environment and leverage
NCBI resources for that kind of thing so
we ask that you document the stumbling
blocks that you run into at NCBI so if
that's something you're interested in
please email bioinformatics training at
NCBI with that what I'd like to do is
take some questions take any questions
that you may have and there are
questions I do not know the answer to
will either answer them on the ftp site
or p
Coover can answer them in person so i
will i see no questions up here on the
question bod it's obviously a pretty
simple and straightforward ncbi minute
so if if there are any questions i'll
give you about the next minute or so to
type them in if not i hope you all have
a good day the fantastic rest of the
week thank you for coming to this NCBI
weather and if you have feedback about
the webinar if you would have liked to
see more some you know was to dwell
longer on a specific thing please feel
free to email webinars at NCBI or
actually just put those comments right
here in the question all right fantastic
well I don't see any questions thank you
to those who said thank you and like I
said I hope everyone has a fantastic
week and good luck with your research or
whatever else it is you do
you